[Music]
in size matters news oh yeah really
depends yes it doesn't submitted by
Caesar and Rica
did you say size doesn't matter its size
matters but for you know it does matter
okay he could be funny and that gets him
into bed but then if it's gonna continue
it's all about the motion that's true
that's true it's all about girth what if
it was like this big nope
like a nipple that's like that's a
female that's a female what if I like
this big I say you could have what if he
knows how to tickle your quit like this
see people talk about the length maximum
no it's about the girth the real
question is what is the minimum um I'd
say what is it to hit the G isn't it
like four inches to hit the actual like
yeah but also you need a certain amount
of girth in order to hit if you have
pencil-dick you won't hit it either
yeah take a [ __ ] pencil I mean yeah
this is about four inches but I thought
even if fingers are pleasurable no well
not this that's not what you're supposed
to do supposed to curve look get over
here get over here an African Health
Minister has complained about the small
size of condoms being produced out of
China you know what did you expect
bigger condoms is why this [ __ ]
stereotypes huh
what the [ __ ] because there's true true
black people got bigger dicks I seen it
you've seen it please elaborate because
I was at the Korean gym ki bong which is
the spa the nude mail section and
there's this bad guy he was sitting on
this it was like a curve like it was on
the side right and he was just sitting
down and relaxing and his balls were
sagging and touching the floor and I was
like wow and it is do
like on top of the balls like that and I
was like wow and then there's guys that
walk and it looks like like there's a
like their dick is like an inch away
from their knee and they're already tall
yeah yeah it looks like a [ __ ] it
looks like this no no no no would you
marry and then there's the you know
there's some there's like there's there
are some guys though I saw this one
really really buff like black guy he had
a baby's wiener it looks like it looks
like a thumb probably it could be a
grower yeah not be with about you would
you not be with the guy if his penis was
like too big yeah oh yeah she's the
first person I've ever accepted me so
that's true the first was never accepted
me what oh yeah I know it's so hard what
[Laughter]
I know it's so hard
oh that's obviously too big that's a bad
song the width of it but there's some
penises that exist cuz I've seen many
porns with a dick that's even bigger
thanks for them pretty decent okay not
maybe to think but that's pretty [ __ ]
felt pretty thick though this is the
perfect size this is a perfect when you
put your fingers around around Steve's
dick there's that much space there yeah
damn Steve's a [ __ ] dick champion let
me see there you go he's the first guy
where I had to use my elbow you know
like when you're like this it's like
with your wrist right with him it's like
oh my god take a little shoulder workout
your shoulders are pretty bah that
shit's crazy just like oh my god not
today like you know I've only been with
showers so I'm like I know about how big
it's gonna get but with him was like the
doctor doesn't it what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] wasn't like this before
[Applause]
[Laughter]
were you there saundra you thinks people
that me arm wrestle with this dick I've
always wanted to see I've always wanted
to feel like a big throbbing baby dick
in my hand why just cause like just just
to see what it feels like like a stress
ball no like you know when you see a
bodybuilding oh oh
since I realize I couldn't enjoy it out
of myself
you want to see what it feels like to
wrap your hand around a dick in your
[ __ ] thumb and indexfinger that
doesn't touch ya would you rather touch
a friend's dick or a stranger's dick
doesn't really matter I'm gonna be why
why is that weird yeah why why do you
reveal this [ __ ] like now like why can't
all my Steve's dick Steve and Steve was
like I can get hard and I'll let you
touch it okay cool I mean if it's if it
reads - if it meets my requirements my
friend because I want a big dick so it
has to meet my requirements if it's like
if it's only a little bit bigger than
mind and I do I feel like you might be
kind of confused a little bit so III
will bring in a live pic now I'm gonna
see
gonna touch it touch anybody's dick
right now go gave it go
don't let me about you don't think of
him like him having a I don't but he
said he's the appropriate pickup [ __ ]
with my bare hands
yeah I care about you cannot touch my
lady later when it's a little warmer
because it's cold right now this is Bart
wood Steve he's probably like hey Steve
hey Steve can you can you like flex real
quick oh and then let go hmm yeah I mean
I'm not gonna Jack him off you pervert I
don't think that I just want to squeeze
it to see what it feels like well you
got it you got a spare and then when
they're soft yeah okay you know how when
you do that yeah pull like that looking
is still hard yeah I think that's how it
gets hard I don't think he flexes that I
think he has to be turned on so you turn
him on I just want to compare oh I know
a way to do this wait
you gotta get to your like you are
making a sexual your soul yeah you're
making a sexual I know how you're gonna
do this is very simple you don't tell
Steve that you want a threesome with
another guess what happen
you're gonna tell Steve that you want a
threesome but the only way it's gonna
happen if he is blindfold throughout the
everything right part it's gonna have to
sneak in real quick and just go he walks
out and then that's it and say hey they
go back down that's all I meant to know
that's all I'm not trying to stroke them
I'm not doing it for pleasure or any
sexual how much money money yeah why am
i well this is a transaction so that
it's not sexual it's a business deal no
zero dollars more than zero
can we just change the subject that [ __ ]
[ __ ] this is it's a science project oh
yeah
so Zimbabwe's Minister of Health was
saying at an HIV / aids prevention event
that's the popular condom among the
youth if they're being imported from
China but they're too small so they're
trying to use just suggesting general
Seoul's complex popular then that why is
that the popular one I wouldn't trust
condoms from China anyway that's just
gonna [ __ ] break on you that's just
like latex is so thin your [ __ ] is gonna
seep through it what about the guy that
was the mold for that Chinese dick
here's about her the condom here's about
this news and she's like all sad he was
like the biggest one they have in China
that's a good point how come we learnt
German and Japanese condoms do we do
your Japanese condom the quality of a
condom is like a car like the quality of
their cars matched the condom Mercedes
and BMW and Lexus of condoms that's what
we should begin we don't rich people
condoms believe the same condoms other
ballin calm I think they just do
vasectomy isn't like and it just reverse
it when they want to so but then again I
don't know I like to come though I
wouldn't want to hold and plug that but
you don't know what it you still come is
it really good I like spitting like a
camel
wait what comes that clear oh yeah it's
still the same either so still semen is
just not sperm inside of the semen did
the sperm make it white no no it's the
ejaculation fluid yep I [ __ ] busted
so many times one time that it was
nothing but that [ __ ] no sperms it was
just a [ __ ] clear liquid spin yeah
yep that's what happened I don't know
why that grosses me out more than the
being white it just grows
yeah it's just like your dick drilled
this graph but sixth rule in the
beginning too and the other pre but I
don't like that that's to clean out the
insides
it's like lip gloss I mean I just
pictured you going
I am never sharing water with you ever
again yeah if we are stuck in a desert
and there's a water bottle than a single
one I'm drinking the whole thing or I
will drink what I want first and then
you have the remainder
that is ridiculous grab a stick and go
every [ __ ] morning I knew the way I
miss the [ __ ] lip gloss right now
[ __ ] two fingers and [ __ ] like holy
[ __ ] it's like a little Carmack's tube
that's not the kind David I believe this
[ __ ] because there's um there's like a
dick size average and like someone
created like size average not average
size different countries yeah they did a
stats on dick size averages averages
what's a dick size so if there's like a
map of the world and then you'll see
different countries in and then they'll
show you like what countries what their
averages oh you googled this evidence it
your sex ed books something in your
google search history he just wanted to
see if he was normal it's in like your
sex ed classes in books too there's like
a chart of that and there's also a chart
of what semen tastes like depending on
your duck this would only be something
that a guy would research to like I was
researching with Jess we were together
who had the great idea I went to to do
all the stats the guy that was
they're all stats like who got paid the
break to go gotta be a guy that would be
oh you know what we gotta figure out
this know if this guy that's like my
dick seems small but maybe it's not
small for the country what is the match
what is the you world average then it's
about five point five to six point three
inches
they also said I think I read a survey
or something where they said that
because most guys they also aren't
answering these surveys correctly one
count for them they do it in a survey
nah dude they gotta have them they got a
[ __ ] flick that dick they got a sign
up for that job no I don't wants to sign
up for that I just want to feel one well
you have to feel different types it's
not fair I only I don't care about the
small ones I just want to know what a
big [ __ ] erect Godspeed help them out
please
well how big is his is like over eight
inches or just about there it's a maybe
a little bit bigger you measured it you
put a why would see but I don't want to
talk about this [ __ ] well tell Steve
I'm a fan and I'd be down just do the
plan the threesome plan and it's easy
nobody gets hurt you know we made a
religious contractor sanctimonious it's
not for sexual pleasures Bart's a
scientist yes and he demands to know all
he wants to do is squeeze it with his
calloused hands is that wrong
[Music]